professor on can we talk about someone
approaching a crime scene and collecting
fingerprint evidence who would that
person be and how would they approach
this evidence the person that it would
be is what we term a criminalist they
are the ones who are they study
criminalistics they are the evidence
collection team everything that is
collected not just fingerprints but
swabbing for blood semen saliva perfumes
could week a new sentence - these are
done by criminalist let me explain it
quickly if I may there's three types of
forensic scientists if you will there is
the front line which are the criminalist
they go out and collect and preserve
everything
then there's the laboratory criminalist
that does runs the assays and runs
everything through the equipment through
the gas spectrometer and through
microscope microscopy microscopes all
that stuff that's the lab technician the
third level is the scholar practitioner
that writes the algorithms if you will
for you know that that the laboratory
people would use to say Armstrong 2013
states that this is person is five foot
six to five foot nine because dot dot I
myself am a forensic practitioner I do
research and I teach and I hope to
create out of my research an algorithm
one day but to answer your question
specifically it is a criminalist that
does all of the work and they are
certified it is not an easy topic to do
to roll prints do you because there's
rolling live prints rolling prints off
of a decedent rolling prints off a
decedent that's been in water there's
also there all sorts of techniques and
ways of rolling a print and that's just
collecting prints from a hand then
there's also finding a print which we
call a latent print latent means hidden
basically so there's
finding the prints and developing them
you know pressing things with the powder
and and then the and the brush and all
that stuff
there's so much to just a fingerprint or
thumbprint or an ear print or footprint
we have ridges and and valleys all over
the place and we have oil all over the
place and proteins and you can get
things off of this and because this is
for writers I'll give you a trick a
bloody fingerprint do you you do the
blood or do you develop the print blood
gives you DNA and and other you know do
they have STDs and stuff like and now
with a human genome mapping god knows
what else they can find out from it
depending on how much how big the sample
is where is working with a fingerprint
get you in the eighth ascend the
fingerprint database is getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger but so
is the DNA database what do you do all
you design
you